-It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So since Wrestlemania
is happening this weekend
on Peacock, I sent out
the hashtag, #MySignatureMove.
We asked you guys to tweet out
something funny or weird
that only you do.
-Ooh.
-Yeah. Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love the interaction.
We love it.
So thank you so much.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"My Signature Move"
responses from you guys.
This one is from @DevonMccarty.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @GeorgeGmitro.
-Mm
-He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's a great move!
-Now that I'm gonna do.
-That's a great move, right?
You found the glitch
in the Matrix.
This one's from @miketbarrett.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ooh.
-That's --
That's brilliant.
-That's brilliant.
That's thinking.
-That's what I'm saying.
None-ion rings.
-Yeah.
-That's fantastic.
-That's genius.
-Yeah.
That human is a genius.
They should make none-ion rings.
-Yeah.
-I would eat them.
-With some Hunts ketchup.
[ Laughter ]
-This one is from
@JakeWilliamsArt.
He says...
-Oh!
No.
-Oh, snap, no.
-Oh!
-No!
-2, 3...
-You're gonna love it.
I think you're gonna love it.
-I think
I'm going to enjoy this.
I like Cheetos.
I think I like
Flamin' Hot Cheetos.
-Okay. Here comes
a Flamin' Hot Cheeto.
Don't rub your eye.
-All right, here we go.
-Or...
-All right, here's my Cheeto.
♪♪
[ Light laughter ]
[ Audience groans ]
[ Crunching ]
[ Drum roll ]
-[ Laughs ]
Oh!
Wait a second! Wait!
Hey, Mikey,
I think he likes it.
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, I dig it.
♪♪
I think not bad.
-Yeah.
I think they should make
Flamin' Hot peanut butter --
-Peanut butter Cheetos?
-Yeah, like a combo flavor.
What do you guys think?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh.
You're saying like a Combo.
It's got peanut butter
on the inside, like a Combo.
-No, that's too much work.
-Oh.
-It's cheaper if you just
put a chemical powder
that tastes like it.
[ Laughter ]
-Xarthron-b or Garble-X-7.
Oh, now he's doing a plain one,
cleanse the palate.
Nice.
Then you can hit
the pole later on.
[ Laughter ]
But don't burn anything
with your fingers.
[ Laughter ]
-Could we get smaller napkins?
Is this from a dollhouse?
-That's a sample napkin
to see if you want a one?
Do you want a napkin?
-Yeah.
-Do you want a napkin? Okay.
We just wanted to make sure.
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Budget cuts
really hit hard, man.
[ Laughter ]
Gosh.
This one is from
@carriesmith1123.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @joeydestefano5.
He says...
[ Applause ]
I used to do that.
Mom's not looking,
just throw in a Reggie! bar.
[ Laughter ]
Mister --
"Mr. October."
[ Laughter ]
Reggie Jackson's nickname.
-Mr. October.
-Yeah. That's what they called
Reggie Jackson.
-That's correct.
Reginald...
-J. Jackson.
-P. Jackson.
Mr. October.
-Rocktober.
Mr. September.
-Has anyone made Rocktober jokes
for Dwayne Johnson?
-No, not yet.
-He has a movie coming out.
I guess he's too big now.
They won't release his movies
in October.
-I would, yeah.
-Second release.
-Yeah, the
Dwayne "Rocktober" Johnson.
-Oh, I'm not saying he should
be called Rocktober.
-You're saying the movie should?
-No, the movie shouldn't,
either.
But when they release the movie,
they go, "This Rocktober..."
-Nice.
[ Laughter ]
-Right?
You see what I'm saying?
So if he had a-a-a-a-a theme,
like a Halloween theme...
-Yeah, sure.
-...maybe
a Halloween-themed film...
-Perhaps.
A John Carpenter type of movie
where some sort of teen
is either scared by
a Michael Myers or not?
-No, maybe a teen
of a certain age
is chased through the woods.
-Yes.
-By a man with a knife.
-Yeah. Punctured
with the blade of such?
-"Coming this Rocktober..."
[ Laughter ]
-"This Rocktober..."
-"...your life is about
to go down the Dwayne."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-♪ I feel good ♪
[ Bell dinging ]
♪♪
-Oh, snap!
-What is this bit?
-I forget.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, "Hashtags."
-Oh, "Hashtags."
-And it's "My Signature Move."
-Oh, your signature move.
-Yep, here we go.
[ Clears throat ]
This one's from @MichDeGroot.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Aww.
-That's a good -- That's fun.
-That's fun.
That's a funny move.
I like that.
-That's cute.
-This next one is from, uh...
[ Chuckles ]
It's from comedian Todd Barry.
-Oh.
-In his signature move,
he says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's definitely funny.
-That's Todd Barry.
-Yeah, it's very Todd Barry.
So, weirdly enough,
he was joking, but that is
kind of his signature move
being funny and kind of esoteric
comedy, like dry comedy.
[ Laughter ]
So, Todd, this weirdly is
your signature move.
I like that.
This last one
is from @Deadhead722.
She says...
There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.